thank you for joining us America it's a
millionaire theme hour we are talking to
millionaires this hour people who have a
net worth at least a million dollars if
you don't know if you're a millionaire
it doesn't mean that you have a million
dollar income a year it means that you
have a 1 million dollar net worth your
net worth is defined as what you own
minus what you owe your assets minus
your liabilities when that equals a
million dollars you are a technically a
millionaire now it doesn't mean
necessarily that you're living high on
the hog it doesn't mean you're opulent
houses or big cars or something it just
means you have some money whether it's
in real estate or whether it's in your
401k or whether it's in cash some people
are cash millionaires but that's what
we're talking about here we want to
learn how people really build wealth in
other words not what the mythology is in
the political spectrum all right we are
talking with Hank in Birmingham who has
a 1.4 million dollar net worth most of
its in mutual funds not counting this
$250,000 house his income was 40 to
about 200 he's 57 he's a college
textbook buyer and our salesman and your
degree was in what Hank I was a
journalism major okay cool and your GPA
mine was mine was 3-1 my wife's the
college professor in the house or her
GPA was higher what was it oh I have no
idea but I bet it was close to four
probably a four oh yeah so how much of
the 1.4 million in wealth is because you
borrowed money to build wealth no it's
been exactly the opposite we've never
made a penny by borrowing money it's
it's by borrowing that we've gone the
other way yeah until we started
listening to you okay cool so how long
ago did you listen to you said you went
to a Birmingham thing ten years ago
about 10 years ago at UAB yeah and what
was their net worth at that time I don't
know maybe two three oh wow so you've
gone up over a million dollars in that
ten years yeah I think so Wow that's
cool so what part has giving played in
you building wealth a huge my wife and I
tithe at our church and and in recent
years we've been able to
able to give to missions and other
another charitable giving we we give
quite a bit and you know the irony Dave
is that before we started seriously
saving we could we felt we couldn't tie
because we were out out earning yeah out
spending our earnings and and we never
found that way to tithe it's only when
we started putting their principles into
practice that we were able to tithe
faithfully and consistently cool and a
million dollars later here we sit yeah
yeah so the most expensive pair of jeans
you've ever bought Oh probably 80 bucks
okay no how many new cars did you buy
before you had a million dollar net
worth ah - so cool
okay how many books are you read
nonfiction in a year average
oh I don't know a lot I read five books
a month at least
oh wow okay a lot of fiction what's the
best non-fiction book you've read in the
last 1224 months not counting Dave books
you know right now I'm reading a great
little book about writing called the
yard of war for writers it's a hobby of
mine cool having a lot of fun a lot of
great advice in it good for you do you
think someone can start where you were
10 years ago and had a million dollars
for their net worth in the current
environment absolutely absolutely
there's no what did you do they caused
that to happen one of the big parts of
it you know the main thing Dave is we we
we made so many stupid decisions we just
decided to stop being stupid and we
decided to we ramped up our 401k savings
big time and we already had a decent
base if we did one smart thing all along
it was investing in the 401 K and then
compound interest just takes care of the
rest of it so when you took the debt out
of the equation got on the budget and
ramped up the 401 K it took off yes sir
yeah that's it
okay cool hey man thanks for calling in
you are a hero I'm honored to talk to
you you're a millionaire there's only
about 10 million of you out there
there's not a lot of model it's a fairly
rare animal hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from
ciao you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or twenty seven
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or $500,000 in
company